hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Gotham episode 16 video all
about flying Grayson's and the Joker or
you know who seems like the character
they're turning into the Joker Bruno
Heller talked a lot about how they're
trying to be faithful to the comics but
because the Joker doesn't really have a
set origin story they're getting their
version of it it's just like the flash
TV show is taking a lot of core elements
from say like the Wally West era and the
Barry Allen era and combining them so
it's not exactly like any set comic book
story but but it's as close as possible
on all best episode of Gotham so far if
you're gonna start with an episode of
Gotham and you haven't been watching it
yet this would be a great episode to
start with especially if you're trying
to get your friends to watch it too so
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet starting with
top five moments number five Bruce is
having nightmares about Killer Croc it's
not necessarily a Killer Croc Easter egg
but the drawing in his journal at the
very beginning of the episode looks
suspiciously like Killer Croc I don't
think it's a coincidence that they cut
really quickly it's a fish Mooney
beneath Gotham I think that that area
where they are the sewer system
I think that's beneath Gotham somewhere
maybe even below Arkham City somewhere
if you want to get really specific with
killer Crocs you could say this looks a
little bit like Mike Mignola's most of
you probably know him as the Hellboy
creator but he also drew Batman for a
while if we do get to see Killer Croc on
the show I suspect we would see the
human version of that first we haven't
really veered into Gotham mutants yet
but I do think this show before the show
ends however many seasons it gets we'll
do something like that on to number four
penguin is gonna get a little bit of
help with his nightclub I really like
the way they opened the episode with
with penguins mother singing that song
across all the different scenes it
actually almost sounded like fish Mooney
could hear it beneath Gotham somewhere I
don't think that area they're in is
beneath the club I just
I think they edited it that way so you
would associate that place with Gotham
later when he's playing heart and soul
on the piano you kind of wonder what his
heart and soul is like is it gonna be
this nightclub when Falcone gave him the
club he bumped him up to top tier status
so I think the club has a lot of
sentimental value to him especially
since he spent so much time working
there for fish Mooney when he was first
coming up the butch reveal was so much
fun don't you just wonder what zazz did
to him in that basement I almost don't
want to know that's like that's like HBO
territory
he's like the Theon Greyjoy of Gotham
now
I saw a lot of you guys tweeting me reek
stuff during the episode hopefully he
hasn't lost any of the body parts that
reek has lost his dark as some of Fox's
stuff gets I I don't think that they
would veer into reek territory literally
I do like the butch character they they
spent some time developing him so I'm
glad that they're keeping him on the
show as part of this brainwash storyline
and in the promos you see fish Mooney
eventually comes back so I think she'll
take butch back to at a certain point
either take him back or kill him that
actually he'd be even more interesting
like if she senses that he can't come
back and has to kill him of all the fish
Mooney specific characters I think she's
the only one that's safe and I'll talk
about it more at the end of this video
but the way they edited this was so much
better I mean they usually they try to
cut away for a comedy like whenever the
blood splashed on the woman's face when
penguin killed that guy that was
heckling his mom usually they do things
like that pretty often but it felt like
some of their creative choices were a
little bit different in this episode and
it felt like it was just so much more
fun moving on to number three meet the
flying Grayson's as expected dick
Grayson's parents were just really young
in this episode it just explains the
timeline about how Robin can be younger
than Bruce I really like what they did
with the Lloyds and the Graysons
they had like a Hatfield and McCoy thing
going on or you could think of it as
like Romeo and Juliet
I really wish Gotham could always do
this good of a job in developing its
side characters like this whole carnival
felt like it existed outside the world
of the show and that's really what it
takes for characters to feel real they
had this whole American Horror Story
carnival theme going on it was so much
fun
if he never watched that show it was a
Clancy Brown show and he's actually on
the flash right now so it's this fun
meta thing going on I kept expecting to
see Sarah Paulsen walk by in the
background with two heads a lot of you
told me you thought you heard Mark
Hamill's Joker laugh during this big
crowd scene
it might have just been the Jerome
character laughing off screen speaking
of which let's talk some backstory on to
number two The Joker's backstory
explained this is where I feel like the
show asked that most of us as viewers as
people who are very familiar with the
Joker character what they're saying is
is that Jerome's mother was just really
promiscuous and at one point a long time
ago had a relationship with the Cicero
character and they just never told him
who his real father was he slowly went
crazy because of what his mother did
because of her behavior which is
interesting because it's kind of the
same thing that's going on with the
penguin and his mother
only their relationship seems much more
positive or codependent however you want
to think about it both very twisted
relationships but one seems a little
more loving Jerome is like what would
happen if the penguin ever snapped
inside like if he ever just couldn't
handle his mother anymore I really do
hope that they do not kill Carol Kane
off anytime soon
she's really the scariest character on
Gotham right now and my number one
moment obviously Jerome cracks starts to
become the Joker
they definitely ad yard.that laugh at
the end that's not a natural laugh I
mean I feel like you could practice and
get it halfway there but they probably
tuned it up and post a little they did
say that they would play around with the
idea of who would become the Joker so
you could always say that Jerome is just
a crazy person but I do feel like based
on what this episode put forth this is
the character who will become the Joker
right now it seems like he's headed to
Arkham they haven't introduced the Hugo
Strange character yet but they did say
that his character was very important to
the creation of a lot of the super
villains that we'd see eventually so
what I'd really like to see is this
Jerome character interact with Hugo
Strange
and then develop a really twisted
relationship inside Arkham let me know
that what was your favorite moment and
what would you like to see them do with
this Jerome character next I feel like
we all want to see him inside Arkham
with you go strange I feel like that
would be the best possible scenario just
to address some of the other characters
in the episode so I know everyone's
wondering what's going on with fish
Mooney and who the manager quote-unquote
is at the end of the episode whenever
they played the promo for episode 17 she
said the name dr. dolma ker so I'm
thinking that that's who the manager is
and they're using those people they're
harvesting them for organs because of
the Bruce scene in the boardroom what
I'm hoping is is that they weave all
these like organ harvesting crazy
Arkham City plot lines together with
some of these board members that's
really what you want to see at the end
of a season you want to see that all
these different plot lines that are all
over the place
are all connected they all have a focal
point and I think the Wayne board is
gonna figure into that they didn't seem
like they were a cartoon villains
whenever Bruce was meeting with them but
hopefully they'll develop some of those
characters a little bit better that
Bruce can go up against they'll develop
a villain inside the board I'm sure you
guys saw a ton of Easter eggs here are a
couple that I haven't mentioned yet
Halley's Circus is actually straight out
of the comics that's who the flying
Grayson's originally performed with
right now in the new 52 universe
Dick Grayson has actually gone back and
used them to help solve
crimes so they've actually brought the
circus back into the contemporary
stories Catwoman and I be eating the
serials kind of an Easter Egg for Gimli
doing new characters for the General
Mills cereal boxes
Gimli famous DC artists actually did
versions of Count Chocula freaking berry
and Boo Berry so if you haven't already
you should actually go buy a box of
Count Chocula
just because Gimli drew it they
mentioned the Hellfire Club that's
obviously a Marvel group so I think that
they were just playing with that I don't
think the Hellfire Group is gonna turn
into anything big the Red Hood gang is
coming in next week's episode but that's
a completely separate group I kind of
mentioned it before my only real thumbs
down was the Barbara scene you know I
like that they had this Catwoman IV
Barbara scene I could feel the humor
that they were going for but it just
didn't play with me
the montage felt a little force but that
might be because I love Morena Baccarin
so much Leslie Tompkins character is the
spirit of adventure the Gotham has been
missing all season she's probably one of
the best new characters they've ever
brought on the show so there's no way
you would believe Gordon would leave her
for Barbara which unfortunately means
that Leslie Thompkins is probably going
to either one to leave Gordon so just to
remind you guys next week's episode is
Red Hood gang I'll explain their back
story in the comics whenever I post that
video be sure to subscribe to get it
new episode of the flash tonight that
video will post after the episode airs
it's gonna be like part two of the
two-part firestorm story that's going on
we're also pushing into time travel so
what you guys wait for that stuff to
drop you can click here to catch up on
the flash before tonight's episode and
you can click here to watch last week's
Gotham thank you so much for watching so
let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tonight
you